james pearson's book camelot in the
cultural revolution is the best book
ever written by about the kennedy
assassination
and it is about the liberal reaction to
the kennedy assassination
because liberals to this day have pinned
it
on the white supremacists in dallas and
that's just crazy
he was killed because he was a cop
because he was an anti-communist i mean
that's pretty clear
that ali harvey oswald killed john f
kennedy because john f kennedy was
anti-communist
and we now are starting to piece
together that he may have
felt he was acting on orders from the
soviet union
just give me uh cuban missile crisis
it's kind of 101 a little bit about what
led up to it and what his decision
making was that
she ended up being so wonderful so
nikita khrushchev is the premier of the
soviet union
and his new client state in cuba ever
since fidel castro had taken over
in 59 and uh
khrushchev sent nuclear missiles to cuba
so they'd be 90 miles away from u.s
territory in florida
when this is discovered uh kennedy tells
the soviets they have to get out
immediately
the soviets don't agree tension could
lead to
the firing of missiles and kennedy gets
khrushchev to face down
kennedy gets him to say okay we'll pull
our missiles out
and it was big egg on khrushchev's face
back in the soviet union
one tidbit about that the documents that
came out in november
on the presidential assassination do you
see just this past november
a couple months ago do seem to indicate
that khrushchev gave the order after
that humiliation
to all networks globally the kennedy
should be assassinated and lee harvey
oswald may have begun his preparations
because of that directive
wow all right so i do want to talk about
the assassination obviously and
even just the way you said that there's
so much of it that's hard to piece
together and how far do you want to go
down the rabbit hole and follow the
conspiracies and all that but we will
get to that
but what what was the final moment that
got khrushchev to turn down i mean did
kennedy basically say
well i know there's the line of course
but was it really communicated like
this is going to be world war three
well i think to answer that question um
we have to speak russian and have access
to the archives
because i think what happened is
that khrushchev felt pressure at home as
a lot of people have said
soviet union really was a status quo
power and the polyp bureau
began asking khrushchev um are you going
to take our lives away from us are you
going to take our summer dacas on the
caspian sea away from us
and our are 10 of us in the soviet union
who have a nice life
um what are you doing would you please
back down it seems that whatever kennedy
was doing
the real folding happened on the soviet
side
and khrushchev was not the first among
equals i mean he did not he was
barely premier of the soviet union so it
seems that and we don't have enough
information on this because it's behind
these source walls
that the russians backed down because
they realized khrushchev was acting
crazily yeah
this may sound like an amateur question
but did they ever actually speak the two
of them through translators was there
ever
or everything goes through the
communications i'm gonna have to review
there's a great book on this called one
hell of a gamble
uh which has all the documents this
amazing book by er ernest may and phil
zelikov from uh from the 1990s so let's
look that up yeah yeah
how much after the cuban missile crisis
i mean that really changed everything in
american foreign policy right i mean it
really was
a huge catalyst for a lot well we argue
in our book um that the the big change
foreign policy-wise came a year later
when kennedy countenance
assisted in the assassination of the
south vietnamese president dm
in november just a couple weeks before
kennedy's assassination and that seems
to have been the tipping point in
vietnam i'm telling you
i've been listening to a lot of the
kennedy tapes on vietnam with mcnamara
and everything else
it is true that kennedy had no real
interest in a long-term war in southeast
asia
no he didn't what on earth he was doing
helping to assassinate gm
and i have no idea and that was a big
mistake so was that really just
because he had this again he had this
thing
drilled into him from his father from
childhood about communism and maybe
that overrode the intellectual part of
him that said let's not get into these
intractable wars
yeah i think i think gm in vietnam was
one of those people that madden kennedy
because he again like king he didn't
want you to bring him into
into his circle and then have you burn
him
you know dan wants to see the american
guy yeah he's our guy in south vietnam
and he just kept alienating people and
making life difficult for the monks and
everyone
and kennedy's like hey you're supposed
to be our guy and i'm john f kennedy
yeah so at some point kennedy will break
and just said okay you're gone
gone in this point meant assassinated
and
that is rare in the kennedy ambits
um and it ended up um being not good for
american and vietnamese fortunes for the
next you know
10 years yeah what else do we need to
know about just sort of
the the personal side in terms of what
was going on in the white house
during those years yeah i mean he ran an
elegant white house
and all that uh he did have his his
girlfriends really kind of did
uh that that side of him did desecrate
the white house and i think we have to
understand
how much do people know i think it's
hard for people to understand in a
modern sense
of what could have before social media
before everyone had a phone and all that
like what did the average person know
about that at the time or what was the
media even saying
right about that well uh kind of the
wisdom of crowds i think the electorate
largely understood what was going on
even though there's no hard evidence
in the papers and so forth and there
really wasn't any hard evidence
i mean now we know about his swimming
nude and this is with the pools and the
secret service having to hold his drinks
and all that stuff and we know all about
that now
and judith hexner may have been killed
by the communists because she was a
plant and
all that not judith but gifford
pinchot's niece
um i believe that because kennedy had so
many kind of
crazy affairs in the white house the
press felt that it was
burned like we're not allowed to report
this and that's really what gave us
watergate because nixon's things were
kind of small in comparison
and the press was like we got burned
then we're not going to get burned again
wow that's fascinating i've never heard
anyone lay it out like that so basically
they kind of played along with jfk
because they were trying to be nice
maybe he was a little bit of their
guy sort of but then but they felt
embarrassed by it i mean they felt used
yeah i mean we're just shutting up about
this yeah and then the next time
a suggestion of that came around they
just went with a sledgehammer
interesting that's really interesting
sorry so obviously we have to talk about
the assassination
um tell me a little bit just in the
weeks leading up to it
what was going on in the presidency yeah
i think that was really kennedy's
highest time as president thurston clark
has written a great book about kennedy's
last hundred days
from august to november 1963 but he
really was coming into his own
and i i think that's true actually uh he
kept talking to the secret service agent
hey isn't this a great day to be alive i
mean
he was really into it um his tax cut was
going through so rice cup was going
through the soviets were gone
um he just assassinated gm that's the uh
footnote
so how public was that by the way was
that oh it was publicly it was
completely public well
no it was presented as a palace coup
that it was internal so the american
fingerprints were not clear
at the time and his ambassador his new
ambassador henry cabot lodge
uh who he defeated in the senate race uh
in the 50s
uh was kind of the fall guy so it
appears that he put somebody in
in saigon who would have to endure the
dirty work
so aside from that kennedy's enjoying
watching polaris
missile launches and he's laughing at
the senate finance committee which is
trying to hold up his tax cut
and he's just like you guys could try to
hold it up but you know i'm going to win
so he's really kind of coming into his
own and then november 22nd
yeah so what was it you know i don't
know how did you know how to ask this
question properly because you've see
everyone's seen so much about it but
the news starts breaking and it's hard
to imagine what breaking news would be
like
at that time now right can you kind of
frame that a little bit yeah i
we can see these they're on you know
youtube um
so we soap operas back then were live
so there would be live actors yeah you
know acting out
the soap opera and they were broken into
you can watch these again on the
internet right now uh with bulletins
from walt from uh
walter cronkite and so forth uh saying
that there's been an incident in dallas
president's been shot
and then they would go back to the live
acting and then the actors would just
start acting again
about the drama of the soap opera um but
it took about
probably about 45 minutes to an hour for
for people to realize that
it happened to you yeah when did the
conspiracies start popping like
immediately were people going something
is wrong here
you know why was he taking this sort of
circular route
around with the topless car and all of
that stuff like
were people immediately doing that well
yeah i mean the trip to dallas itself
was controversial it was in in the
planning in october november because
dallas was a hotbed of kind of what we
might call
white supremacy and people worry well
and kennedy said it's nut country down
there they're kind of anti-canada even
though they voted for
kennedy because of johnson on the ticket
so everyone was worried about
his not getting a good reception in
texas from
the kind of call them racist uh you know
whites if you want to use those terms
but the trip was totally successful on
those counts he went to fort worth and a
huge celebration and he went to
dallas and everyone loved them and the
last words perhaps spoken to john f
kennedy were from connelly's wife in the
car
well it's all over now and you can't say
that texas doesn't love you
and then he was blown away wow
incredible so
you know i think the first time that i
paid attending attention to this was
probably in high school when i saw the
movie jfk
uh i assume you've seen them yes i have
yes so how far is as someone that really
cares about this
story and all that i mean how far down
all these rabbit holes are you willing
to go
it sounds like some of it's still
unfolding as new documents still come
out
but just for you as someone that sure
that is interested in this
yeah i mean i think um there are a
couple aspects of the assassination that
we have to take seriously that we have
to kind of lose our sophistication
about oh oswald acted alone now hold it
uh dilly plaza is the best place
possible for an assassination
that's where it happened that should
interest us in terms of conspiracy
theories
can you explain why i mean there's that
slow turn there's just the points of
vision oh there's a it's at the end of
the parade route so the parade is over
and then there has to be a right turn
and a left turn that goes then
downhill so the parade's over which
means the intensity of the experience is
over and the secret services
um interest will start to wane and that
was a
absolutely essential in the
assassination then
so there's that setting and there was a
school book depository right there
within the graciel
and an overpass too it's stemmon's
freeway
well it's a perfect place for
assassination so therefore we should
stop this pseudo-sophistication about
oswald acted alone the other thing too
is kennedy was absurdly good at making
enemies
i mean he just made enemies i mean his
father made enemies for a living yeah
so by the way we've talked about 45 or
50 minutes now we haven't even said in
military industrial complex once
which obviously had some some issues
with him which we can touch on
yeah right so um
so and oswald also had connections to
beat the band uh with the mob
the soviets the cubans you know i mean
so that's also very
fruitful jack ruby oswald was killed
jack ruby has connections to beat the
band so these are all suggestive
nonetheless
james pearson's book camelot in the
cultural revolution is the best book
ever written by about the kennedy
assassination
and it is about the liberal reaction to
the kennedy assassination because
liberals to this day
have pinned it on the white supremacists
in dallas and that's just crazy
he was killed because he was a cop
because he was an anti-communist i mean
that's pretty clear
that ali harvey oswald killed john f
kennedy because john f kennedy was
anti-communist
and we now are starting to piece
together that he may have
felt he was acting on orders from the
soviet union
we may have felt that's an interesting
way of phrasing it what do you mean may
have felt
well oswald is quite a character and
what was going on in his head we don't
know we do know that he met
um he went to the cuban embassy to meet
a soviet
assassination expert in september 1963.
the documents that just came out imply
that it was understood in late 1962 that
nikita khrushchev after getting burned
in the cuban missile crisis
may have sent out some kind of broad
order into the global soviet network
that it would be desirable if the
president states were assassinated
and that order may have been called back
because of
pressure within the polyp bureau at
khrushchev you're still acting like a
nut khrushchev was forced out in 1964.
but once you squeeze the toothpaste out
of the tube it's done hard to get it
back in
so it may be this is speculation but
grounded in some sources yeah um that
oswald was part of that
initial outreach and then may not have
stopped
and then went ahead with it yeah so
basically you're willing to go
down these these routes you sort of have
to i
i mean the more i read about this and
the more of these documentaries i watch
you know i've got a carl sagan book
right there and i always quote you know
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence
so i don't know that we have the
extraordinary evidence but there were so
many pieces
in play here yeah that that make it seem
hard to believe yeah i think the one
thing that is
firming up pretty well is that oswald
killed kennedy because he perceived
kennedy to be
anti-communist so it was the left
that killed kennedy because kennedy was
too right-wing
um that's been lost over the last 50
some years that is firming up through a
lot of sources
that's the most important thing i think
to conclude then with the deep story of
oswald's connections are
okay that's interesting from the grassy
knoll now there's no shot from the
grassy knoll it's impossible anyone's
been to the
plaza realizes that's the physical
impossibility all that stuff it does
appear
very clearly that oswald fired those
bullets he hit the traffic light
then he hit kennedy in the neck then he
hit kennedy in the
the magic bullet that's very easy to see
with a heavy case bullet
full metal jacket yeah that will act
that way the ballistics aren't a
question oswald shot kennedy
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell